what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with spawn largely because of
the launch of king's fawn which looks
like it's gonna be really really cool
and it looks like it's gonna be a pretty
big event i have no idea how deep this
is gonna go but there's a few things we
need to clear up because the last time
we covered spawn he fought god and satan
met the mother of existence and all that
kind of stuff so after that story came
something called spawn resurrection
which basically rebooted everything kind
of to a degree not really it changed a
few things here and there one of the
things that changed was that god and
satan were no longer these two things
where they were basically just two sides
or really just the same side of the same
coin where like heaven and hell were all
just scumbags and heaven basically just
had a better depiction of themselves on
earth in terms of how humanity believed
them instead it follows more in line
with what you would define as being
traditional judeo-christianity right
god's a good guy satan's a bad guy and
there's just a war that's been going on
between heaven and hell ever since
that's one of the big things that kind
of came out of this and that's why over
the course of king spawn if you're
reading it you'll hear him allude to the
idea of god in satan how god's the good
guy satan's a bad guy all that kind of
stuff that's one of the big things that
changed but there are a couple other
things to talk about here so what this
does initially and really kind of
explaining these as we go through this
initially picks up in like a little
preschool basically is what it looks
like right bears class you know just a
bunch of little kids sitting around and
it almost looks kind of like a like a
christian school we're not really given
a definitive example but the reason why
we kind of say that is because the
teacher basically starts asking the kids
if they know what the bible is and one
of the kids responds to saying that it's
like a comic book right there's monsters
and good guys and bad guys and it's like
a great big cute story which in all
honesty is not an incorrect description
of the bible right that it's kind of
like a comic book without the pictures
all kinds of stories and stuff but the
important thing here is that this guy
kind of says okay like let me just go
ahead and set something on his phone he
says there's not a whole lot of time
here so something that i want to make
clear he actually starts reading from
the book of psalm and basically you know
as he as he does this and his phone goes
off the whole school blows up right the
whole place just gets blown to pieces
and he says like happy shall he be who
taketh and slams thy little ones against
the stones and that's the crazy thing
right like it's taking kind of this
literal interpretation but literally
everybody dies here and that's what's
kind of nuts because immediately it
picks up with spawn right it picks up
with al simmons really kind of narrating
this whole thing right and he says this
is how they always start by targeting
then feasting in a spectacular fashion
as they can on those two innocent to
defend themselves right largely talking
about both angels and demons here
because one thing to keep in mind is
that while god is quote unquote good and
satan is quote-unquote evil at the end
of the day spawns still spawn and he
sees them both as scumbags
he doesn't want to have anything to do
with either of them but he says the
saddest part is that humanity is unaware
that heaven and hell have been attacking
them for centuries sometimes just for
sport other times with specific purpose
and to draw out their enemy is their
goal now that's kind of a big thing
because what you do here is you switch
over to al simmons talking with jessica
priest while they're kind of watching
this funeral unfold now here's the thing
about jessica priest right jessica
priest is interesting she is technically
she spawned but she's not the first she
spawned the first she spawned was a
chick named nix and the way this worked
is she was literally a girl and we can
kind of do an origin on she spawn if you
guys are interested but she was
basically a girl whose mom died when she
was really really young she started
messing with magic at a very young age
she eventually formed a kind of cult
right a witch's coven with a couple of
her friends one of them bailed out and
things just kind of popped off for her
but she eventually ended up becoming she
spawned later on she dies and her friend
jessica priest basically takes up the
mantle now who's jessica priest okay in
the early days of the spawn comics the
person who actually killed al simmons
and set him on the path to becoming
spawn was a guy named chapel but chapel
was a character who i believe was owned
by writer rob liefeld and ultimately
there are some legal issues and that
meant that uh todd mcfarlane could not
use chapel anymore so he switched it out
and basically had it that jessica priest
was the one who originally killed al
simmons now of course as you can tell
over the course of the spawn comics i
wouldn't say they're besties but they're
certainly not enemies right there's a
little more there was a little more
going on there than initially met the
eye but they're really kind of working
together in a lot of different ways one
of the other things that happens is that
he's kind of saying like a lot of this
really seems to be them trying to target
me or bring me out but i don't really
know why and indeed it kind of makes
sense right that the war between heaven
and hell is one of those things where
definitive answers are not readily given
to al simmons largely because of the
fact that the the comics really do stick
to the kind of judeo-christian ideology
that the motivations of god and satan
are largely mysterious outside of like
this bargain that was somehow struck
that satan would take the souls of the
wicked and god would take the souls of
the good and heaven and hell and so on
and so forth but in terms of what each
one actually wants why they're doing the
things they're doing it really is a
desire to kind of humanize these
otherwise inhuman beings but more so
than that it's designed to kind of
expand on the overall mythos and the
nature of these characters in the spawn
comics and to make them seem really
ambiguous and their motivations
extremely clouded and so what ends up
happening here is mark rosen basically
chimes in and kind of says like i'm
trying to find shadow players but i
can't find one right i can't find any of
these like hell spawn esque characters
any basically other versions of spawn
that exists out there because there are
right there's nightmare spawn there's
medieval spawn there's gunslinger spawn
which is amazing and we can do the
origins on all those characters if you
guys want like throw you know leave a
comment down below and i'll check the
video to see whether or not you guys are
interested in that kind of thing but
there's a lot of these different
characters out there but mark can't
really find anybody now who's mark rosen
okay mark rosen was at one point in time
a writer for a magazine or for a
newspaper and was trying to make his way
up you know things didn't quite work out
for him ultimately he came across spawn
and the way this worked was that for
those of you guys coming from like the
batman comics in dc mark is very similar
to uh to like oracle right where he's
kind of the research guy and it made
sense because over the years the spawn
comics were modified expanded and
adjusted by todd mcfarlane to really
illustrate this idea that given this
grand crusade and how far reaching
across the world the actions of god and
satan are that it's not something that
like a single guy in some alley in new
york can handle on his own that he
needed he needed help from people right
he needed other people to kind of help
him do the research and to do these
things that he couldn't necessarily do
on his own so while it is still a pretty
small team it's a very effective team
right and that's one of the things that
kind of happens is mark's like i can't
really find any shadow players here and
spawn's kind of hard on him right he's
like man just keep looking right just
keep on going and mark of course goes
back to kind of doing some more research
and so on but one of the things that he
talks about is that with jessica priest
being a mother herself he says you have
to understand where this mother of this
girl simon is coming from right just one
of the kids that was taken out here and
he says like at the end of the day yes
she's grieving yes she's angry yes she's
hurt but what she wants are answers and
standing around staring at the dirt
paying respects are not going to give
her answers right like actually doing
something will give her answers now one
of the other things here is he basically
reveals there is a kind of sigil that he
had found which he doesn't really know
how to decipher he doesn't really know
exactly what it means but kind of
looking around in the rubble he
ultimately located it and is seeing if
he can't find somebody who can decipher
it he was able to decipher it to a
degree but not on the level that he
needs to fully understand uh what's
going on with it right and so what he
ends up doing here is actually making
his way kind of looking at the dossiers
of these different kids and so on and so
forth and things along those lines even
going as far as to say the sigil also
says there's a list somewhere files with
names of every shadow player stuck here
on earth and again he refers to them as
the soulless basically the shadow
players being angels and demons who are
stuck in human form here on earth
because the gates to heaven and hell had
basically been shut off and been uh
destroyed by spawn those you guys aren't
really aware in terms at least as far as
angels and and demons showing up on
earth they can't just show up
willy-nilly right they kind of it's
almost like the curcumin gates from like
x-men right they have to pass through or
come through these particular locations
but if you shut those off they can't get
in here and those individuals who are
here can't get back right so it's almost
kind of spawn's quest to take out those
who were stuck here and sort of call it
a day while they largely remain
underground with all kinds of different
positions right some are businessmen
some are business women some are
politicians some are just running gas
stations out on the highway like they're
all they're all over the place right
they're very very difficult to find and
so the result of this is that you
actually end up having uh having really
spawned picking up with a couple of
these guys one of whom is a politician
the other one is what is an effect of
mistress but obviously in line with
satan and it's one of these crazy things
because what it shows here is that it's
not as though all the demons and all the
angels despise each other and they're
fighting against each other and that
kind of a thing that there are
affiliations here now how deep those
affiliations go aren't readily given to
us but basically this guy is working for
god more or less and this girl is
basically working for satan right even
if they are cut off from their
respective creators and that's why spawn
shows up here and says how disappointed
would your masters be if they saw their
loyal servants in the arms of their
enemies right like basically angels and
demons banging how disappointed would
they be to find that out
and so ultimately he tells this guy
right this senator he's like i need you
to read this for me now this particular
girl says like spawn has no no dominion
in this location which spawn immediately
subjugates this chick and again spawn
has the power to destroy them so that's
why it's kind of a big deal here when
spawn shows up because quite literally
their life is on the line and so he
tells this guy like read this for me
tell me what i need to know now
initially he only really gives spawn is
just like some surface stuff right well
it's a blueprint it's this right just
enough to
you know for what it seems to be get
spawn interested enough to leave but not
enough to give him anything meaningful
but ultimately spawn catches onto that
exceedingly fast and says this is all
stuff that i know man you're not telling
me anything that i don't know you're a
terrible liar we've done this dance
before tell me what i need to know or i
will kill you and i will kill her and in
response to that he says it's metatron
metatron is here on earth he was
basically stuck here after the you know
he was trapped here after the dead zones
were closed and like that's it right
like he's here somewhere and he says
like like basically the sigil is kind of
a location to where uh to where metatron
is and he's like you know where like
where would metatron be and he's like
according to the sigil it's the same
place where hell birthed you right new
york city and so he ends up traveling
back home and then of course we pick up
with metatron now one of the funny
things here is that in the spawn comics
metatron is given to us and i'm not i
can't really speak to judeo-christianity
or catholicism i don't know if that's
absolutely the case really i don't know
much about metatron outside of what's in
the comics but in the spawn comics
metatron was at one point a human who
convinced god to make him an angel right
the only human to ever do so and he
basically says that at the end of the
day metatron was just like spawn except
that he worked for god and he was
basically a servant of god the big
difference here is that unlike metatron
who loved being a servant for god that
spawn did not enjoy being a servant for
malboja and by extension satan right he
didn't want to have anything to do with
those guys he wanted to kind of like be
broken away and do his own thing and not
be tied down to them and so that's why
there's a there's a few huge differences
here now with metatron kind of making
his way around and actually watching
this video footage of things going off
right this this school blowing up that
you actually end up having a homeless
guy who runs up on him and like starts
touching him and asking him questions i
mean you guys know how sometimes
different people not just the homeless
but like different people just don't
really understand like social boundaries
every one of you out there watching this
video right now knows at least one
person who does that and if you don't
that person is probably you but
regardless
you know this guy is just violating
every social custom that we have here in
the states
in terms of like being around people
right you don't stand super close to
people things like that he basically
starts pissing metatron off and so what
ends up happening is metatron starts to
whisper in the ears of this guy but his
voice keeps getting louder and louder
and ultimately the guy's head explodes
now spawn picks up on the fact that that
was obviously metatron you know once he
arrives in the scene he kind of gets a
look at what's happening and the reason
why is because as he explains it
metatron's vocal cords can basically
destroy a human being right so literally
it's like black bolt from me and humans
from x-men right like he has a voice a
quality sonic scream that can kill
people metatron of course vastly more
powerful but basically the principle
remains the same in terms of how his
voice works and so locating the building
where he was initially dumped when
malboja first turned him into hellspawn
uh he shows up here and basically
locates where it is that metatron's
supposed to be the problem is once he
gets in there metatron's totally
destroyed right this guy has been
obliterated and literally there's like
all these different things on here it
says here lies metatron he wasn't strong
enough for our cause so basically it's
an external force that works out there
that killed metatron but here's the
thing this is not some throwaway moment
right metatron was not some government
spy he wasn't just some regular dude who
did some things no metatron was quite
possibly the most powerful of the angels
on earth that operated in the service of
god and so because of that you're
literally talking about a person who is
powerful enough to not only kill an
angel but to rip them to pieces right to
tear them limb from limb and just strew
their guts all over the place right it's
crazy how violent this is and so what
you end up doing here is switching
basically switching over to a place
that's simply described as being 200
miles north of brooklyn right so we
don't really have any exact location
here but basically this guy says god
told us that he would kill the firstborn
sons of egypt that his way was righteous
in leviticus he says eat the flesh of
your sons and in psalms 137 the lord
implores us to do what and they and all
these different servants here respond
smash the heads of the little ones and
that's when this guy says yes exactly
and so my flock will leave a pile of
bodies so high the entire world will
mourn that's when he'll come when our
king will reveal himself and we shall
deliver him all the glory and all the
punishment he so richly deserves all
hail king spawn so basically these guys
seem to be agents we don't really
definitively know if they are servants
of heaven hell or possibly both who have
unified against spawn but they're
looking to draw him out and most likely
looking to kill him but again i'm
excited about this man king spawn is
amazing but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments if you guys
want me to cover the origins of the
different versions of spawn that are out
there because gunslinger spawn is
probably the coolest one nightmare spawn
looks the best like he looks amazing but
let me know if you guys want me to cover
that stuff and uh yeah i will catch you
all later
peace
you